you know ever since i was little i would
try to like make movies or interview
like i'd set up my basement chairs
everywhere and pretend to be oprah and
interview the neighbors and
make these little videos and i'm like
well maybe i can like try my hand at
like tv or modeling
so um i didn't tell anyone this because
i was like they're gonna tell me don't
be ridiculous it will never happen for
you so i took a polaroid camera and i
went outside by my garage
and i literally took like 70 selfies so
then i took the yellow pages yellow
pages millennials were probably like
what um and i opened it up to commercial
agencies and i
put each one in an envelope and i mailed
70 of them out and i just
waited
and thought well if i hear back great if
i don't then there's my
trajectory you know um 26 soul qualities
that a human needs to develop in order
to reach their fullest potential um
fearlessness is number one because if
we're riddled with fear we don't even
want to see we don't even want to get on
the path in the first place so what we
want to do is we want to just start to
see and witness in these practices so
we're sort of like pulling things out of
the dark corners and we're starting to
look right so the word um enlightenment
again means freedom we can never be free
if we are controlled by we get hijacked
or we react to these patterns we don't
even know what's going on we just think
to ourselves we project we blame we're
like oh that person's an [ __ ] all
right i just don't like them or whatever
it is this is it's like always out here
versus shining the mirror inside and
seeing oh you know my true nature is
bliss and unconditional love and what
are the things that have happened that
create distortions and that like why do
i act out in these ways or why does this
really bother me i i felt like some days
i would wake up and i would be in this
like deep depression i'd be like i don't
want to do anything else with a live
face down on the floor and i would tell
myself this is just a bad day it's a
write-off like the whole day is gone and
unfortunately that's not true because
there is always something you can choose
to do to change your environment your
way of thinking what you're doing why
they can snap you out of it and
i don't
resent myself for that because that kind
of procrastination of going like this is
too hard to deal with it comes out of a
place of fear which is completely
understandable because it's terrible if
you if you have awful anxiety if you are
really stressed if you are seriously
depressed maybe you're grieving or
something like that it's horrible to go
through so of course you want to tell
yourself like i'm i just want to give up
and i just want to be defeated and so
many people are at different points and
everything helps so for some people they
need the medication to give them that
strong foundation so they can then make
changes to their lifestyle because some
and this was this is me you know i've
been on antidepressants and there was a
period of my life where
you know i couldn't snap myself out of
it or readjust my mindset or change my
lifestyle to be better for my mental
health i couldn't get out of bed i
needed the antidepressants to stabilize
my mood there were points where i
couldn't have these conversations with
myself because i didn't have the
self-awareness or the perspective to
realize how toxic my self-perception was
until i spoke to a therapist and she was
like
boy you're crazy
this is uh you know what you're saying
right now it's not true you are you you
just have this awful perspective of
yourself and not only is it making you
sad but it's stopping you from growing
as a person because you're just holding
yourself back for me from my perspective
because looking at the deepest level of
who we are these limitless spiritual
energetic beings and we've manifested
into this physical meat suit on a place
called planet earth
why did we come here because we had
karma to resolve
and the karma being limitations fears
perceptions of inadequacies and life one
again one of my favorite quotes a lot of
people share is life will present you
with people and circumstances to reveal
where you're not free 100
so you're always going to attract
whatever it is that you need in order to
be that subtle sort of form of
resistance and sloughing to be able to
remove the constraints that currently
inhibit the limitlessness of your soul i
create i've created challenges my whole
life
to overcome my emotional fears fears of
rejection fears of looking bad fears of
being judged
and i'm always thinking of i try to tell
people this if they want to increase
their confidence
write a list
not the shameless this is the fears list
of all the things you're most afraid of
i'm not talking like
i don't know
an alligator or something i'm talking
about i like the emotional fears sure
yeah the deeper stuff i'm afraid of like
my
my wife leaving me i'm afraid of
whatever
and so my whole life i've been afraid
emotionally
and
at certain stages i just say i'm sick
and tired of feeling this way so i was
always afraid to talk to girls because i
would get rejected by them all the time
and i never thought i was interesting as
like a kid as a young teenager
and one somewhere i was like i'm sick
and tired of feeling scared every time a
girl walks by me i would just be scared
i was like i don't want to feel this way
and i gave myself a challenge this whole
summer
after i was 16 i gave myself a challenge
in the summer i was like every time i
see a girl
it doesn't matter if i'm attracted not
attracted i'm gonna go up to her and i'm
gonna have a conversation
because i was so terrified to do it i
was just like i need to do it until it
doesn't feel scary yeah
what's the greatest gifts i gave myself
yeah desensitize yourself yeah i was
just like it doesn't matter how many
times i get rejected i still love myself
and i got one
letter back that said we'd love to meet
with you downtown chicago and uh
come meet us
so i
borrowed an outfit from jc penney's kept
the tags on
and uh took the bus
downtown chicago and went to this agency
and i sat down
and uh she said i brought you in here
just to help you out
by telling you you'll never
make it in this business i left her
building
and was on the curb crying after i was
done crying i kind of looked up
and across the street was the playboy
building
and i was like
oh
don't do that your mom will kill you
so i found myself walking across the
street saying myself let me just ask the
secretary a question so i go to her and
i say how do how do girls become
playmates and she said not by walking in
they send in a photo of himself in a
bikini
and we get about a million pictures a
year so
take a picture and send it and i said
okay
turn around press the elevator button
and i'm waiting
waiting
and this guy walks past and he said are
you inquiring about being a playmate i
said
yes
because i still wasn't sure
and he said you know we have a
photo shoot happening right now if you
feel comfortable putting a bikini on and
just taking a a quick picture and we can
send it to half i got a phone call a
week later that's half said you're
officially missed october 1993 and i was
like
oh my god this is so crazy and how am i
gonna tell my parents so for me danica
oh my gosh when i started doing this
work
i used to think okay i like to move
things along the most um
one of the things that bothered me the
most was when people interrupted me
right
or i would go into this you know
explanation let's say oh phil should
need a lot of dairy and then they
wouldn't agree with me so part of me was
like oh you know
it's just annoying i would just like
toss it off as this person's annoying
but i started to really sit with this
okay so the it gets deeper to answer
your question we build and build we
start to see what's there and then we
start to dissolve it in different ways
and different practices of bringing in
more light because these different these
lunar aspects are you know darkness and
what is darkness darkness is an absence
of light darkness is not necessarily
evil we don't want to create shame and
you know weigh ourselves down it's just
that we need to nourish these aspects of
us so for me i could see oh you get
really impatient when people interrupt
you when they don't agree with you what
is that so then i would sit with it and
through this work through these
practices i could see oh the reason it
bothers me so much is because it's
triggering some very primal um fear in
me that i'm not good enough to be seen
or heard and underneath that was like
i'm not if i'm not good enough to be
seen and hurt it's because i'm not
lovable right like a deep deep deep
primal wound you know things that
happened in my childhood
and so once i saw that as the root the
behavior was an extension
but the root wound which again we take
you sequentially into healing this
was this oh i don't feel lovable and
once i saw that danica then i started to
tune into the ways in which we give
ourselves love
no more like dancing around or all the
ways in which i was giving my power away
trying to get the love and reinforce
myself and validate myself which is
really validating the ego anything from
outside instead it was like well i can
show up for myself i can give myself the
love i can again self-soothe validate
and the healing that came from that was
so tremendous because what happens then
danica and this is what this is what
cures a lot of relationship issues is we
then become whole as individuals so when
we're with our partner we're with
someone else a friend we're not trying
to get anything from them the language
that we use that you cite
is derogatory by virtue of the fact
that's still how we look at ourselves
and it's flip it's it's twofold so
that's how we incarnate like i say we
arrive with our bucket of fears and the
game is who can get rid of them the
first you know the quickest
then you become an inspiration for other
people to do the same
but really it's also without the
constriction of self-judgment or
self-criticism you don't actually have
to learn the language of love
see it's easy to love the parts of you
that you love it's easy to love the
parts of you that you like or that you
find attractive
but love that is
[Music]
is able to embrace all of the parts of
you that you think are ugly is love see
love doesn't distinguish between forms
and so going back to how we sort of
prior to this with talking about love
love that is based on you know well you
do what i want you to do then i love you
that's that's not love that's
conditional dependency that's preference
yeah
so ironically by virtue of the fact that
we have these narratives and the
dialogues about ourselves that are
derogatory then that part of us is
actually the conduit to which we get to
manifest what real love is which is
being able to embrace all parts whatever
you fear
running towards it not away from it
like go with your intuition even if it
scares the [ __ ] out of you even if it's
going to upset
people around you that's fear
but
and who knows i was terrified of going
to la and making it or not making her
failing and my aunts and uncles
condemning me to hell
i was like you know what
i'm just gonna run towards it i've
nothing to lose i've got a feeling
inside this happened to work out the way
it did i'm just gonna run right towards
this fear
and
thank god i did honestly and that's what
i've continued to do in the course of my
career is um
anything i'm nervous about i go okay
thank you emotional guidance system
thank you for alerting me that that's
what is what i should do now mind you if
i'm fearful of um
jumping off of a cliff that makes sense
of course you should be scared of that i
don't say them go jump off a cliff it's
more about like opportunities because a
lot of people are scared
to quit their jobs and take a new one
yeah break up with their boyfriends or
girlfriends you know because they're
scared to be alone
to me that is a sign from emotional
guidance and that's exactly what you're
supposed to do
run towards it